[Music]
hi I'm Matt dollops I'm a professor at
McGill University I study cosmology and
I also build telescopes and today I'm
gonna take you on a bit of a journey
about to show you something of the new
telescopes we're designing and putting
on the sky today
so the last two speakers are people who
primarily calculate how things will look
on the night sky they calculate how the
Cosmic Microwave Background will look
how it's bent and deflected by light and
nobody would listen to them if their
calculations and predictions hadn't been
borne out with real instruments and
technology that look up at the cosmos
above us and prove them right
actually they only have to be right some
of the time before they get famous but
it's that technology those telescopes
that are the other important ingredient
to understanding the cosmos now most of
the images you're used to seeing of the
night sky of the universe above us are
images that are typically full of
structure complexity and beauty zooming
in on a narrow part of the sky to see
things like planets beyond our own solar
system to zoom in on the details of
what's inside distant galaxies or to
find out that a great amount of what
we're seeing on the night side is
controlled by black holes something that
we'll hear about later in today's talk
I'm going to tell you about technology
and telescopes that zooms out and allows
us to image the whole sky to bring back
that big picture that ultimately lets us
understand how the universe as a whole
is born evolves what it's made of the
dark matter the stuff that's in there
that isn't all just us and ultimately
how it's going to evolve to its future
fate these are the types of telescopes
that I've been focusing on building and
I'm going to show you a new revolution
in the way that we're starting to look
at the sky a new
type of telescope that we're looking at
the sky with now I showed these little
cartoon sketches of objects and
typically the images you're used to
seeing are objects that are revealed in
the same wavelength that your eye looks
at the sky with in the optical band
let's move out to larger scales and look
at wavelengths that are about a
millimeter this is where the Cosmic
Microwave Background is and let's join
that journey of revealing the night sky
go back to the 90s when Kobe was
launched and look up look up everywhere
in the night sky with a telescope that
has scanned it all what do we see well
we see a universe this is real data this
is from that Kobe satellite and it cost
NASA the United States government about
a half a billion dollars to bring this
information down what we see is a
universe that on these very very large
scales is the same in every direction we
look in and appears to be in the same in
every location the laws of physics that
govern our universe appears to be the
same everywhere now this image which
comes from a very early time in the
evolution of the universe if the
universe was the ade lived to the age of
a person so that today were about a
hundred years old this would be the
first day of the life of the universe
this telescope brings back that image
now this is what this guy looks like
let's let's just take a moment and feel
the human journey of it imagine if you
built this telescope if you spent years
putting putting this telescope together
and you looked up the night sky and you
saw this this is a very accurate image
the early first image was less accurate
but it showed the same thing what you
think you've now discovered an intimate
part of the physics of how the universe
is I'd probably pick up the phone and
I'd call my mother maybe and say the
telescope's broken no matter where we
look we see the same thing it's it's not
turning on properly we've got to go back
and that actually was the thought
pattern when people looked up and first
saw this saw that the early universe is
a place that is simple that is symmetric
that is beautiful in this very very
special way
and so piecing that together this early
signal from the universe to today where
we have this complexity and structure
and beauty is part of that great vision
and view of cosmology to understand the
equations that govern that evolution and
that's what we're trying to do with the
world of cosmology and we've put
together quite an amazing picture with a
which agrees with all of the
observations we have out there we have
an expanding universe the dick and Gill
described to us that appears to be
governed driven by what's inside it the
matter the ordinary stuff baryons people
planets stars galaxies the dark matter
that we don't quite understand very well
even though they fit the equations that
are put together and dark energy their
telescope I'm going to tell you about
today tries to fill in the gaps between
the present universe that's full of all
this structure and the early universe
that is so so simple it's trying to
image the universe when it was about 1/2
to 1/5 its present age when this when
the universe is taken over by its normal
expansion and driven out faster and
faster through through dark energy ok
before I can tell you about this
telescope I have to just remind you what
I think everyone in this room already
knows telescopes are exploration
vehicles it's like the ships that
brought us from the old world to the new
world
telescopes allow us to look out at a
given point on the night sky and explore
what's there but they're way more
exciting to that because they are also
time machines and you know this here in
the front row I'm looking at our future
speakers and they're 10 feet away and
light travels at about 1 foot every
billionth of a second so snap when I
take a photo of these people I don't see
them as they are now I see them as they
were 10 billions of a second ago so I
won't know if they're making fun of me
for a little moment and at the back of
the room I see you you're a hundred feet
away I see you as you were ten billions
of a second ago and when I look out at
the Sun the sun's light takes eight
minutes to reach me so I see it as it
was eight minutes ago big deal
when I look out in the cosmos with a
very very powerful telescope and I look
far far away I get to see the universe
as it was I'm
million years ago a billion years ago
and so forth and since when I draw my
picture of the evolution backwards in
time we get to a more compact universe
where all of us everything eventually
gets to the same location I am seeing
the universe as a whole as it was a long
long time ago so by taking these images
at different distances I am learning
about the evolution the growth of our
own universe and that's key
now we're used to looking at the sky in
the optical band we're used to looking
with our own eyes in the optical band
the telescope I'm going to describe
today is looking out not in the
microwave where the images that have
been shown so far are which is about a
millimeter to a centimeter or so but way
out in the radio band the same band
where your cell phones and your
computers communicate that's a nice band
to be in because the wavelengths are
long and the frequencies the repetition
rate of the oscillation of light is long
enough that we can record it with
traditional devices let's take a journey
not to the South Pole where the previous
telescope that Gil showed is but instead
out to Western Canada to the Dominion
radio Astrophysical Observatory a
government lab a government zone where
we've protected the environment from
radio frequency interference and we're
building a new telescope called the
Canadian hydrogen intensity mapping
experiment the construction of this
telescope is a collaboration of three
universities and the National Research
Council of the University of British
Columbia University of Toronto and and
McGill University this is what the site
looks like it's shielded from nearby
towns by small mountains and everyone
can see the obvious telescope in this
image it must be over there and then in
the medium right hand side there's a big
radio dish that's not the telescope I'm
talking about the telescope we're
putting together right now chime are
these halfpipe skateboard like ramps
that are shown on the left-hand side of
this green here it is a highly
non-traditional telescope because it
does not look at a point in the sky by
taking a big dish rotating it to where
it wants to look and focusing all the
light down on a small camera instead it
lays on its back and there are no moving
parts whatsoever
collects all the electromagnetic light
that falls from overhead and uses a
giant computer to deconvolve that
information and understand the sky that
must have produced it from above I'll
show you a little bit more about it
so here's time it consists of these four
cylinders there are about 20 meters wide
and a hundred meters long so all in all
it's the scale of about six NHL scale
hockey rinks to give us all something
work we're familiar with peppered along
the center of each one of these
cylinders are these feed lines and
there's a thousand different radio
receivers that lie along these feed
lines so that's the feed line that you
see here and each one of these is just
an antenna and it collects all the radio
information that has fallen on the
cylinders sitting behind it is a giant
computer and it takes the information
from each one of these antennas and
processes it in a way that it can figure
out whether the combined light that it's
receiving is coming from this location
or that location or somewhere else on
the night sky the amount of information
that's flowing through this telescope is
on the same scale it's comparable to the
total amount of information that the
world's mobile data network is
transferring right now it's a whole lot
of information that's one of the reasons
we're choosing to build this new
paradigm of telescope that receives all
the light and calculates what's going on
this new paradigm of telescope at these
radio wavelengths because of those
longer wavelengths we can now afford to
buy and build the computers that do this
processing a photograph of time with the
obligatory night sky it doesn't need to
be dark for this telescope to operate of
course now with the traditional
telescope you choose your objects you
have large Committees of people that
figure out where they'd like to be
pointed and you pointed this galaxy or
the star of this quasar or whatnot with
a telescope like chime the beauty of it
is that you get to puzzle in the pieces
between everything else every night with
a telescope like chime we see the entire
overhead sky and that's really important
for a field like cosmology where we're
studying the entire evolution
the universe and it's also going to be
really important for fields like
transient science where we're looking
for things that are going pop and boom
on the night sky and we need to monitor
everything that's overhead you'll hear a
lot about that this afternoon as well
and that's one of the other big Forte's
of a telescope like chime so let's take
a moment to see how it works I've drawn
a one cylinder here and I've put just
one antenna in that cylinder and it
looks up at the night sky and the red
and the blue colors here are the part of
the sky that that antenna sees and the
the image is of radio image of the night
sky and the part that's highlighted here
the circle is the horizon that's what
you can see from Horizon to Horizon at
one one point in the day now this isn't
a very useful telescope because if
something goes pop and boom over here or
here or here I won't be able to tell the
difference it'll look like just one
signal but when I move forward and I
take this cylinder and I put a lot of
antennas down it and I run the
information into a computer I can then
separate out that big slosh across the
sky and divide it up into separate
little places that I look in the night
sky and I can start to say what where
something happened or where the light is
coming from and as I build more of these
cylinders so in this case I now have
four cylinders and I have many antennas
down the cylinders I can take all that
information that's coming into my
telescope and deconvolve it so I'm
looking in all of these different
directions simultaneously this is great
astronomers don't have to argue with
each other about where to look we're
gonna look everywhere on this big beam
we're missing one key component though
because the telescope doesn't move and
there's a whole lot of sky over here
that I'm not looking at right now
fortunately though the telescope doesn't
move planet Earth spins around once
every day and so in the course of a day
I get to map out the entire overhead sky
spun around the North celestial Pole
this telescope is at a latitude of about
45 degrees so the sky is spinning around
this point and now with this new novel
type of technology where I'm moving the
complexity of my telescope from the
camera into this back-end computer that
does the processing and I don't have
moving parts every night I get to see
the whole overhead sky and do my
cosmology do my transient science with
it
so there's time the Canadian hydrogen
intensity mapping experiment which we're
putting together right now we've built
all parts of the telescope and it's
being assembled for its first light at
the end of this summer or early fall
looking up at the night sky able to see
overhead able to see off to the north
and so forth there are of course some
things we can't see things that are
shielded by planet earth itself now one
other thing I want to emphasize here
I've shown you some technology and
cartoons of technology but the real
thing that's novel and innovative in
here are the people that are putting
this together and that's where our real
resource is and where the real
challenges are the technology that went
that is going into building the chyme
telescope or the technology that went
into building the South Pole telescope
did not exist when those telescopes were
conceived we needed bright people to get
together in the lab and develop the
technology to make those telescopes
happen so people tell people build these
telescopes so with telescopes like chime
we're moving into a new world where
we're able to image not just points on
the night sky but the entire overhead
sky and monitor and record what's going
on there and so I hope the next time I'm
giving a lecture like this I'm able to
show you exactly what's going on in this
period of the universe from about half
its present age to a fifth of its
present age so that we can string
together the very early universe with a
very late universe and understand its
evolution thank you
[Applause]